[Music]
drex here from drexfactor poi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
and today
i'm going to teach you how to do
that absolutely earth shaking combo from
uh the instagram reel that i posted
yesterday before we dive in i just want
to give a quick shout out to the friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard lane
machinski and becca beckonen thank you
so very much for your support for my
work and my mission
so real talk it took weeks to make that
video happen uh one week alone just on
developing the choreography because i
needed something that was going to be
able to loop and something that i could
start from both a dead stop as well as
worked carrying momentum through all the
way as i was playing around multiple
loops of it it wasn't easy but i did
come up with something i really liked in
the process and now for those of you who
are curious i want to show you how now
there's a lot going on here and a lot of
transitions are happening super duper
quickly so i'm going to classify this as
an advanced combo here's the tricks that
you'll need in order to get it down
waist traps
[Music]
windmills
c caps
need your spiral wraps
need your waist straps or flowers
in spin throws
[Music]
and split time opposite in spin flowers
i will go ahead and leave links to
tutorials for all these tricks down in
the description as well as up until if
you're watching on youtube must also be
said this combo incorporates pieces of
two other combos that i've shared over
the course of the past couple years i
will also leave links to those two combo
tutorials down in the description as
well as up on screen i'm gonna show you
the combo at full speed then take you
through it step by step and then show it
to you again in slow motion
[Music]
oh goodness
how did we get here well i needed
something that was going to loop fairly
easily and that took up anywhere between
15 to 20 seconds of time
so i actually used an old
choreographer's trick and i borrowed
from stuff that i'd already written
namely two combos that i've done
tutorials for before the first one many
of y'all will probably recognize as
being this combo that goes back and
forth builds up momentum goes around up
top and results in a c cap yeah
here's how to do just that part of it i
actually had to like shorten it up a wee
bit in order to make it fit for this
combo but
there's still more or less the same
pieces in place number one you start
with a reverse weave over on your left
hand side before switching over to a
forward weave on your right hand side
and from here you build up momentum
and do a quick
windmill around your head and stall out
the poi in your right hand as you come
around down below your left from there
the right hand poi gets flung around
over to your right or back side and you
get it spinning in the opposite
direction as your left hand poi
do a c cap
bring it back down there is of course
just a little bit of leg work that i'm
doing here as well to kind of like add a
little bit of panache to it as well as
some level changes uh namely that as i'm
doing this reverse weave over my left
hand side i'm bringing my
right foot over to my left ankle in cupe
and then when i switch over to the other
side of my body i bring my
left knee up over my right hand side and
passe
and i use that to
bring my thumb around for that windmill
as i'm coming out of that windmill i'm
also taking a lunge down to stage left
and as i switch over to stage right i'm
switching the lunge over to my right
hand or my my stage right here as i go
up i bring my left knee up with it and i
come down with both feet as the poi kind
of splat out at the bottom of that cap
so after the poi have gone splat my next
move is to pick up the momentum in my
left hand poi here as my right hand poi
comes around and that results in a
spiral wrap
this is going to of course set me up for
doing that
anti-spin meteor flower
how do you get there what does the
momentum look like well after i do the
splat and i get both poi spinning i just
pass the left hand poi over to my right
hand and just let them continue to go
around until they do the spiral wrap
of course i add a little bit of panache
into it by leaning back on my right foot
and i bring up my left hand with it yes
that is important i'm so glad you asked
and from here i bust out into that
um that that meteor flower the one that
is based in doing a waist strap all this
really is is going back and forth
between two beats so to turn this from a
couple of two beats into a flower all i
got to do is raise my hand up and drop
my hand down as i go back and forth from
side to side i of course am taking it
over top going from right to left and
down below going from left to right
this is how i get to anti-spin because
these poi are spinning
clockwise relative to me
now after i complete a flower i go ahead
and let the poi wrap around my right
hand and as i do so i'm going to bring
my left hand from out and kind of bring
it into my right hand as though i'm like
compacting the movement of the poi in
the process from here we have our first
actual movement on stage and it's going
to be for me to kind of push out sliding
my entire body to stage left here
now you'll note as i'm doing this
the poi are coming out into a horizontal
plane this should turn
in most cases this would turn into a
corkscrew with my pinky and leading and
of course as that happens i'm going to
take a jump around and let the poi come
to wrap around my left shoulder over
here on stage left from this position
right here with the two poi both
oriented over on my left shoulder
i'm going to go ahead and pull my right
hand out now you'll note
i'm switching the orientation from
meteor to
to being one point in each hand again
and as i'm doing that i'm taking my
right hand out into a horizontal
spin above my head
so we go
here and my left hand poi
is
spinning clockwise in front of me uh
this of course is another one of those
slide movements like i did when i opened
up from the uh one-handed spiral wrap
yeah
now as i'm doing this
i'm going to let my right-hand poi drop
it's going to come around and join my
left hand poi and the two of them
together are going to do
this
you may think that it's a windmill it's
not actually a windmill what it actually
is is you're just doing a waist strap
it's just across the back side of you
right
the only difference here of course is
that i'm taking it up and around and as
i'm doing that um i am also
letting my left foot kind of stick out
and guide me as i'm coming around yeah
um it's actually kind of slowed down my
movement there i want this to feel like
i'm adding and removing momentum so this
is one of those cases where i'm kind of
hanging there in midair for a second
yeah all right so now that i have
finished up that waist strap fountain
here i'm going to polish off my
movements over to stage right by doing
an inspin throw and as the
poi comes over here to stage right i'm
going to let it swing in a pendulum and
then bring it around
boom
to have the two poi meet together in a
two petal in spin flower yeah now for
the final bit of this i'm going to take
a little
shine a step around
in split time opposite extensions and as
i come around to the position where i
first throw this whole thing in i'm
going to go ahead and do a little stall
with my
right hand poi
up to stage right and then bring
my
right foot in to meet my left ankle in
coupe hey what do you know this is the
exact same position we started in ha
what a coincidence right all right so
all that together i take
a reverse weave over on my left
forwards wave on my right go around the
windmill take it down around up in the
cap i splat i come around spiral wrap
do the flower and bring it all around
pop out take it around in a jump
i come out
do that waist wrap around the throw
come back in a flower
do that chane step the stall and i'm
back where i started yeah
awesome let's see that again in slow
motion
[Music]
so there it is i gotta tell you i would
love to see more people doing this combo
for no other reason i worked really hard
on it but if you are one of those people
or at least want to attempt it i would
love to see the results please post your
video to social media and go ahead and
tag me i am at drexfactor on most
platforms i would love to see your hard
work and if you share video of yourself
attempting this combo to say like your
instagram stories i will be more than
happy to share them to my own stories so
that all of my followers can see your
hard work did you get anything out of
this video please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel grow this video would
not be possible were not for the kind
support of all of these wonderful people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
help to make this and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your wonderful support
if you would like to support me in the
work that i am doing trying to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies you can do so by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can do
that either at the link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on youtube there
you can get access to a whole host of
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me get the word out about
flowers to the entire world go give that
a look please and thank you so yeah this
might actually be the single most
advanced combo that i've ever posted on
this channel
i hope there's some people out there
that are up for trying it or maybe we'll
look at it as like hashtag goals we'll
have to see any rate if you have a trick
you want to see me integrate into a
combo please leave me a comment and let
me know
i do actually use that feedback it's
very helpful to me in the meantime i
will leave a link to a playlist of other
combo tutorials i've done down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on youtube please make
sure to get out and flow this weekend
and i'll see you with a new video on
monday
peace